son appel à l'aide n'est pas passée
inaperçue l'athlète christine et axima
nous sky a affirmé que sa délégation
olympique voulait la renvoyer en
biélorussie contre son gré un retour que
la sprinteuse a refusé par peur d'être
emprisonné par les autorités d'après ses
propos dans une vidéo postée sur ces
réseaux ce dimanche
la jeune femme de vingt-quatre on
demande l'intervention de l'autorité
suprême du mouvement olympique
après avoir été accompagnée de force
selon elle à l'aéroport de tokyo
je demande l'aide du comité
international olympique
ils font pression sur moi et ils
essayent de me faire sortir du pays sans
mon consentement
alors je demande au cio d'intervenir
dans cette affaire la sprinteuse a
vivement critiqué sa fédération qui
aurait voulu la contraindre de
participer au relais 4 x 400 m alors
qu'elle devait seulement courir le 100 m
et le 200 m après avoir été escorté par
la police japonaise
kristina ti manus kaya a trouvé refuge
dans un hôtel de l'aéroport de tokyo
afin d'empêcher son retour en
biélorussie de son côté le comité
national olympique biélorusse dirigée
par le fils du président loukachenko
s'est défendu de toute discrimination à
l'égard de l'athlète
comme il a été indiqué compte tenu de
l'état émotionnel et psychologique de
l'athlète biélorusse christina tsy
manouchka ya les entraîneurs de l'équipe
nationale d'athlétisme ont décidé de la
retirer des trente deuxièmes jeux
olympiques à tokyo
le cn au de biélorussie suit de près la
situation et travaillent en étroite
coopération avec le comité
d'organisation des jo et le comité
international olympique
nous soulignons que le cn au de
biélorussie conformément à sa charte et
à la chap olympique est prêt à continuer
à défendre les intérêts de tous les
athlètes biélorusse contre toute forme
de discrimination
le cas échéant plusieurs pays ont
proposé l'asile politique à la coureuse
comme la slovénie ou la république
tchèque
elle a finalement obtenu un visa
humanitaire pour la pologne
christine al siman sky à une athlète
biélorusse est déjà en contact direct
avec des diplomates polonais à tokyo
elle a reçu un visa humanitaire la
pologne fera tout ce qui est nécessaire
pour l'aider à poursuivre sa carrière
sportive
la pologne est toujours synonyme de
solidarité le gouvernement japonais a
annoncé qu'ils prendraient les mesures
appropriées conformément à la loi alors
que kristina ti manosque aia devrait
rejoindre la pologne prochainement n'est
de son côté le marais de l'athlète s'est
confié et rt dans une interview
exclusive explique pourquoi le couple a
décidé de ne plus vivre en biélorussie
et souhaite s'installer en pologne
c'est directement grâce à elle que j'ai
appris la situation
ensuite j'ai vu c'est story sur le
réseau social instagram et c'est après
que toute cette histoire a commencé
toutes ces informations ont été
immédiatement reprise par les médias
biélorusses et ils ont commencé à les
diffuser partout en biélorussie nous
avons donc pris une décision vois je
quitte le pays et christina se rend à
l'ambassade et demande de l'aide
mon avis c'est qu'ils auraient essayé
d'atteindre christina à travers moi nous
avons donc décidé de partir je suis dans
un état d'incertitude car on ne sait pas
ce qui va se passer ensuite
comment christie là pour affaires et si
elle est en mesure d'entrer librement
sur le territoire de la pologne
une fois que je serai sûr qu'elle est
avec des autorités polonaises
je pourrais me calmer et jeux pour y
réfléchir à la manière de déménageur au
pologne